OK, so every December, you see
it.
It's almost like clockwork.
This, this really powerful
narrative starts making the
rounds online, on the news
everywhere.
Oh.
Absolutely, it's unavoidable.
The argument that Jesus, Mary
and Joseph, when they fled to
Egypt, that they were basically
refugees or, you know,
undocumented migrants, asylum
seekers, they use all these
modern political terms.
And it's almost never just a
simple historical observation,
is it?
It's usually wielded as a kind
of rhetorical hammer.
Exactly.
It gets sharpened into a direct
accusation.
Right.
The implication is if you
support modern immigration
enforcement, if you believe in
national borders or, you know,
deportation procedures.
Then you're on the side of
Herod.
You would have been against the
infant Christ.
It's an incredibly compelling, a
very emotionally powerful
argument.
It tries to draw straight line
from a 2000 year old sacred
story right into the middle of
one of today's most heated
debates.
OK, let's unpack this because, I
mean, you can't deny the
emotional weight of that
analogy.
It's powerful.
But our whole mission here on
the deep dive is to chase down
conceptual precision.
And when you look at the sources
you share, they argue that this
whole attempt to sort of draft
the nativity story into modern
politics just completely
collapses.
It does, and not because the
flight wasn't terrifying or
traumatic for them.
Of course it was.
It collapses because the
historical, the legal and
frankly, the geographical facts
just don't line up with our
modern world.
So we're essentially taking a
1st century event and trying to
force it into a 21st century
legal box.
The box it was never designed to
fit in.
The entire exercise fails
because the ancient world didn't
have the modern nation state
that structure, that idea of
sovereign borders the way we
think of them.
It just didn't exist.
So when we make that analogy,
we're collapsing some really
critical distinctions.
We are we're mixing up ancient
internal movement with modern
international migration.
They are not the same thing.
We're treating Roman imperial
subjects, people who had a
specific legal and political
status, as if they were modern
non citizens, as if they were
foreigners with no right to be
where they were going.
Exactly.
And maybe the biggest leap of
all is that we're replacing a
divine warning narrative, a
story about prophecy and God's
protection, with the language of
international refugee law.
Right.
So we're imagining them crossing
this hard, hostile border
between two separate countries.
When in reality, that is the
core historical mistake.
They did not leave their
country.
They did not cross a national
border.
They never entered a foreign
nation state.
Because they lived, traveled,
and fled entirely inside the
Roman Empire.
As lawful subjects, they were
never outsiders, and once you
grasp that single political and
geographical fact that they were
just moving around inside one
massive unified imperial system,
it changes everything.
The whole refugee analogy just
falls away.
OK, so that's our starting
point.
Let's dig into that because it
seems like everything else
hinges on understanding what
Rome actually was.
Here's where it gets, I think,
really interesting.
It does.
To understand the Nativity, you
first have to understand Rome,
and the sources suggest that
Rome is probably the closest
ancient equivalent we have to a
modern continental scale nation
state.
It's not a one to one
comparison.
Of course, we have to be
careful.
Rome was an empire.
It was built on conquest.
It wasn't a democracy.
Right?
But if you're looking for an
analog in terms of, say,
governmental structure, a clear
political hierarchy, and just
sheer unbroken territorial
control, it's a helpful
comparison.
Think of something like the
modern United States, or maybe
the EU if it had a single all
powerful federal government.
That analogy is so important for
just recalibrating how we see
this.
We're talking about an empire of
the time Jesus was born that
stretched from Spain.
To Pillars of Hercules.
Yeah, all the way across the
Mediterranean, deep into Syria
and then all the way across
North Africa, it was this
gigantic political entity.
All ruled by one single
authority in the end, Caesar,
the emperor in Rome.
And that huge scope is the
absolute key to the Holy Family
story.
The land they were on from Judea
all the way to Egypt, it wasn't
split between two different
countries.
Not at all.
Both places, though they were
run a bit differently, fell
squarely under Roman authority.
So let's talk about those
administrative differences
because I think that detail
really matters.
Judea at that moment was ruled
by Herod the Great.
He was a client king.
What does that actually mean?
A client king was a Lobel ruler
who was allowed to manage
internal affairs.
Herod had a lot of autonomy in
that sense.
He could build these huge,
magnificent temples, he could
run the day-to-day government,
and he could certainly issue
terrible decrees like the one
that prompted the flight.
But he wasn't a truly
independent, sovereign king.
Not even close.
His rule was entirely at the
pleasure of Rome.
His power was granted by Rome
and it was sustained by Roman
military might.
If Caesar had wanted to, he
could have removed Herod in an
instant.
His sovereignty was, you could
say, borrowed.
He was basically a regional
governor who got to wear a
crown.
OK, now contrast that with
Egypt.
When Joseph and Mary get to
Egypt, what kind of place are
they entering in Roman terms?
Egypt was different.
It was one of the most important
provinces in the entire empire.
They called it the bread basket
of Rome for a reason.
It fed the capital.
It fed the capital, so it wasn't
a client Kingdom with a local
king.
It was a directly governed
imperial province.
In fact, it was considered the
emperor's personal property.
In a way.
It was ruled by a Roman
official, a prefect appointed
directly by Caesar.
So the Holy Family was moving
from a region with a powerful
local administrator, Herod, to a
region under the direct,
unmediated control of the
central government in Rome.
That's a perfect way to put it.
It's almost like they weren't
moving from, I don't know,
Mexico to the United States.
It's more like they were moving
from a semi autonomous territory
like maybe Puerto Rico.
Or a state with a very powerful
governor?
Yeah.
And they were moving into, say,
Washington, DC itself, where
federal control is absolutely.
Precisely, And because of that,
the entire system was unified in
the ways that mattered for their
travel.
There is a unified system of
law, of taxation, of military
protection and, most
importantly, a shared political
identity as subjects of the
Empire.
And the census mentioned in the
Gospel of Luke is a perfect
example of that unified system
at work.
It absolutely is.
That whole detail about Mary and
Joseph traveling for the census,
it just reinforces their status
as internal subjects.
So let's pause on that.
Why did Joseph, who lived in
Nazareth in Galilee, have to
travel all the way to Bethlehem
and Judea just to be counted?
Well, this Roman census, the
apography, it wasn't just a
simple headcount, it was a
massive administrative tool for
figuring out who owned what and
where, mostly for tax.
Purposes.
Of course, it always comes back
to taxes.
It always does.
Joseph had ancestral ties to
Bethlehem, the city of David, so
the Roman requirement for him to
go back there to register, even
though we live somewhere else,
it just shows you how organized
Rome was at tracking its
subjects across these huge
distances.
So both of their big journeys,
the one to Bethlehem for the
census and the flight to Egypt
to escape Herod, were movements
dictated by or made possible by
the Roman system itself.
Exactly.
The trip to Bethlehem was them
complying with a Roman order.
Their flight to Egypt was them
using the geographic unity that
Rome provided to find safety.
They were never outside the
system, they were moving within
it.
Which brings us to the core
question.
Why was someone from Judea not a
foreigner in Egypt?
Because in the Roman world, for
people inside the Empire, the
lines between provinces were
administrative, not national.
In our world, you cross a border
and boom, you're a foreigner.
Your legal status changes
instantly.
You need a visa, a passport.
But someone born in Galilee,
which was Roman territory, did
not suddenly become an immigrant
just by walking into the
province of Egypt, which was
also Roman territory.
OK, but hold on, there was still
a huge difference between being
a Roman citizen and just being a
provincial subject, right?
They weren't citizens in the way
that, say, the Apostle Paul was
later.
That's an excellent point, and
we absolutely have to be precise
about that.
No, they were not citizens with
a capital C They didn't have the
full package of rights.
They couldn't vote in Rome's
elections.
They didn't have the legal
protections, like the right to
appeal directly to Caesar that
Paul famously used.
They were subjects.
But that status, just being a
subject, was still a world away
from being a true foreigner.
A world away.
Being a subject meant you were
under Roman jurisdiction.
You were part of the system.
You were taxed by it, yes, but
you were also theoretically
protected by it.
It gave you a kind of lawful
presence across the entire
empire.
So the modern idea of being an
illegally present person.
It just couldn't apply to them
when they were moving
internally.
That concept only makes sense
when a foreigner and outsider
crosses a sovereign border
without permission.
They were insiders from the
start.
So their journey really was like
a family moving from California
to Nevada today.
It's the best modern analogy we
have.
The laws and local government
might be different in Nevada,
but you're still in the United
States.
You're still AUS citizen.
You're not crossing an
international border.
The difference is like driving
from LA to Vegas versus driving
from Tijuana to San Diego.
The 1st is just a domestic trip.
The 2nd involves 2 sovereign
nations, international
checkpoints, and a whole legal
process where you are officially
classified as an alien seeking
entry.
The Holy Family story is clearly
the first war.
So the very thing that made Rome
so powerful, its scale, its
unity, is the same thing that
protected them.
Exactly.
The threat was local.
It was from Herod, a Roman
client.
The solution was to simply
relocate to another part of the
same vast Roman system, Egypt,
where Herod's local authority
couldn't reach.
It was the empire size that
offered them a safe haven, not
the legal mercy of a foreign
country.
The moment you see Rome is 1 big
political space, the whole
refugee analogy just dissolves.
It has to They weren't
stateless.
They were subjects of the most
powerful state on Earth, and
they used its internal geography
to escape a local problem.
OK, let's shift gears a little
and talk about enforcement,
because the other part of this
analogy is this image of Caesar
as this, you know, ruthless
border enforcer.
Right, the ancient executive
cracking down.
And the sources are clear that
Rome did take its external
borders very, very seriously.
Oh, absolutely.
Rome was the ultimate sovereign
power in that sense.
It knew exactly where its
territory ended.
If you look at the empire's
external frontiers, what they
call the limes like the Rhine
River, the Danube, the eastern
desert frontier with Parthia,
Caesar enforced those lines with
extreme prejudice.
Those were the real borders in
our modern sense.
Those were the borders.
So what did that enforcement
look like?
How did Rome treat actual
outsiders, real foreigners who
tried to get in without
permission?
It was organized, it was
militarized, and it was often
incredibly brutal.
Roman legions patrolled those
frontiers constantly.
If a group of people, often you
know a whole Germanic tribe,
tried to cross into the empire
without permission, they were
usually met with force.
They were repelled.
Rome dictated all the terms of
entry.
They would expel groups that
snuck in, and if they did let
foreigners settle the peregrini,
they did so under very strict
conditions.
They would control where they
lived, what they did.
Their status was always
conditional and closely
monitored.
So in that very specific role,
defending the external border
against foreigners, Caesar does
kind of look like a modern head
of state enforcing immigration
law.
In that one function, yes.
But here is the critical
distinction we have to keep
coming back to.
That entire framework of
external enforcement has nothing
to do with the Holy Family.
Because it was all aimed at
keeping outsiders out.
Exactly.
The whole system of patrols,
violence and refusal of entry
was for foreigners, and Jesus,
Mary and Joseph were never
foreigners.
They were internal subjects.
The Gospel of Matthew has them
moving completely inside the
borders of the Roman world.
Entirely within.
They never came close to one of
those fortified external
frontiers.
I noticed the sources brought up
a very specific term, the
pomerium.
Could you explain what that is
and why it's a useful idea here?
Yeah, that's a great detail.
The pomerium was the sacred,
ritually defined boundary of the
city of Rome itself.
It wasn't a wall, but a line on
the ground.
Crossing it had huge legal and
religious consequences.
For example, a general was
forbidden from leading his army
across the pomerium into the
city.
It was the line between the
military and civilian world.
In a sense, yes.
And while it technically only
applied to the city, you can
think of the entire empire as
having a conceptual pomerium.
There was a clear line between
the inside the Roman world,
where Roman law and authority
operated, and the outside.
The entire journey from Judea to
Egypt took place deep inside
that imperial boundary.
So all the enforcement
mechanisms that Caesar aimed at
outsiders.
Expulsion, violence, turning
people away at the border.
None of that was ever directed
at people like the Holy Family.
Their drama was local, not
international.
It was.
Now let's run a quick thought
experiment.
What if the Holy Family had been
fleeing from, say, the rival
Persian Empire of Parthia and
trying to get into Rome and
Syria?
OK, so then they would be
foreigners trying to cross the
external border.
Exactly, and in that case, the
Roman soldiers on the frontier
would have absolutely functioned
as the equivalent of modern
Border Patrol agents.
They would have stopped them,
questioned them.
They would have asked where they
were from, what they wanted, if
they had permission.
They might have turned them
away, they might have arrested
them.
That scenario would fit the
modern debate, but that is
explicitly not the story the
Bible tells.
Their flight was inward, not
inward bound.
And for subjects just moving
around inside the Empire, travel
must have been pretty common and
relatively unrestricted.
It had to be Think about it.
The empire's economy, its
military, its administration, it
all depended on people and goods
moving between provinces.
If every provincial line was a
hard international border, with
checkpoints and visas for its
own subjects, the whole system
would have ground to a halt.
Which again reinforces that idea
of belonging.
They belong to the society whose
overall structure protected
them, even if a local official
within that society was the
source of the danger.
They had a defined political
status.
They were Roman subjects that
gave them a right to be within
Roman territory.
They weren't stateless people
begging for entry into a country
that wasn't theirs.
They were just relocated inside
their own country to get away
from a dangerous regional
governor.
So the whole refugee analogy
really depends on pretending
that the administrative line
between Judea and Egypt was the
same as the heavily guarded
Rhine frontier between Rome and
Germania.
And that's the fundamental
conflation.
Caesar's enforcement was aimed
outward at foreigners.
It was not aimed, in a word, at
his own subjects moving from
place to place.
The difference there is legally
everything.
It's the difference between
international migration and a
domestic move.
Which brings us right to the
legal core of the argument.
And this is tough, I think,
because we're just so
conditioned to think in modern
terms, words like refugee,
asylum, deportation, they depend
on a whole legal scaffolding
that just wasn't there in the
1st century.
That's the whole problem.
Our modern system is built on
concepts that would have been
completely alien to them.
Before we even get into it, just
think about what it takes to be
a refugee today under
international law.
You need to have a well founded
fear of persecution.
And this is the key part.
You have to have crossed a
sovereign international border.
You have to be outside your own
country because it's unable or
unwilling to protect you, and
you're seeking protection from a
different foreign country.
Right away you can see the
problems that depends on a clear
line between citizen and non
citizen.
It does.
It also depends on the idea of
lawful versus unlawful presence.
And most of all, it depends on
those sovereign borders
separating different nations,
none of which applies here.
The whole modern infrastructure
is missing.
Think about what deportation
involves today.
It's an administrative process.
It requires immigration courts,
databases, ID cards, a whole
bureaucracy built around the
concept of national sovereignty
and who has permission to be
within the national territory.
Rome had none of that for
internal movement.
OK, so let's break down the
specific legal terms the sources
say are misapplied.
Let's start with undocumented
person.
There was no such thing as an
undocumented person moving from
Judea to Egypt.
The very idea of being
undocumented or illegally
present only makes sense if you
are in a sovereign states
territory without its
permission.
Which again, only applies to
foreigners who cross the border
illegally.
Exactly since Jesus, Mary and
Joseph were already lawful
subjects moving inside their own
country's territory, the concept
was meaningless.
At worst, they were new arrivals
in an Egyptian town who hadn't
registered with the local clerk
yet.
That's an administrative issue,
not an international crime.
It's like forgetting to update
your driver's license after you
move.
It's not the same as sneaking
across a border.
It's the difference between
moving to a new room in your
house and climbing over the
fence into your neighbor's yard,
a completely different category
of action.
OK, second term illegal entry.
Same problem really.
For Roman subjects, moving
between provinces was just
relocation.
There was no law or legal
category that defined that
movement as illegal entry.
They were moving through a
political space.
They had a right to be in.
And the laws that apply to the
external borders, the limes, it
just weren't in effect on the
road from Bethlehem to
Alexandria.
No.
For them, no.
And the third concept,
deportation.
Could a subject be deported from
one province to another?
Not in the way we think of it
now.
Rome could certainly punish
people.
They could exile political
enemies.
They could forcibly relocate
entire populations after a war,
but there wasn't an
administrative system for, say,
the governor of Egypt to round
up subjects from Judea and
deport them back home just for
being there.
Their status as Roman subjects
gave them a right to be on Roman
soil.
So it all comes back to this one
central fact.
They were always operating with
what we'd call lawful presence
inside the Roman.
Always they belonged there.
Which means the story in Matthew
is not about stateless people
begging a foreign king for
safety.
It's a story of internal
relocation to escape a very
specific local threat.
And it was guided by divine
warning.
A divine warning that led them
to a safer part of their own
political system where the local
Tyrants Authority ended.
You know the fundamental
requirement for asylum, that
your home country has failed to
protect you, so you need a
foreign country to step in.
It's completely absent.
In a strange way, their home
country, Rome, did protect them.
It protected them by being so
large and unified that moving a
few 100 miles put them
completely out of Harrods reach.
It's so ironic the argument only
works if Rome wasn't a unified
empire.
If the region had been a bunch
of small independent countries,
then they would have been
refugees crossing a border.
Exactly.
We're arguing against the
analogy precisely because of the
historical fact of Roman unity
and power.
The analogy requires you to
ignore the most important
political entity in the entire
story.
It really shows you how much our
modern political thinking is
trapped by the idea of the
nation state.
We hear migration and we
automatically think
international borders.
It's an intellectual reflex, but
asylum is about 1 sovereign
state protecting you from
another.
Since Rome was the only
sovereign state involved in
their story, the legal dynamic
just isn't there.
So we firmly established what
their journey was not.
It wasn't international
migration.
But the sources then suggest if
you want a real parallel for
their experience, the fear, the
flight, the displacement, you
should look at something else
entirely, yes.
You should look at cases of
internal displacement within
large unified countries.
IDP's as they're called today.
Internally displaced persons,
and this is such an important
shift in thinking because
internal displacement can be
just as traumatic and morally
urgent as an international
refugee crisis, but legally and
politically it's a completely
different situation.
OK, let's look at the first
American example.
The sources give the Dust Bowl
migration in the 1930s.
This seems like a perfect
parallel for the legal status of
the Holy Family.
It's a fantastic analogy.
The Dust Bowl was a huge
catastrophe.
Hundreds of thousands of
American citizens, the Okies,
were forced off their land by
environmental collapse and
economic depression.
They were starving.
So they Fred W mostly to
California looking for work.
Right.
And they're suffering the way
they were treated, the poverty
in the migrant camps, it looked
for all the world like a refugee
crisis.
But they were Americans moving
from Oklahoma to California.
They were in Colonel Migrants.
You were always as U.S.
citizens.
They never crossed an
international border.
They never had to ask Mexico for
asylum.
Their suffering was immense.
Their flight was forced.
But their legal status never
changed.
They were citizens relocating
within their own country.
And that perfectly mirrors the
Holy Family moving from one
Roman province, Judea, to
another Egypt, to escape a local
crisis.
Precisely.
I think the second example, the
Great Migration, is also
incredibly powerful because it
adds that element of fleeing
targeted violence and oppression
which is so central to the
Nativity story with Herod.
The Great Migration is maybe an
even better moral parallel.
You have, over decades, millions
of black Americans leaving the
Jim Crow S for northern cities
like Chicago and Detroit.
And they weren't leaving for
purely economic reasons.
No, they were fleeing systemic
terror.
They were escaping lynchings,
political disenfranchisement,
and a brutal economic system
designed to keep them down.
It was a massive coerced
movement of people seeking basic
human dignity and safety for
their families.
That is persecution.
They were fleeing a system that
was actively trying to harm them
and their children, just like
the Holy Family was fleeing
Herod.
Yes, they were internally
displaced people fleeing an
organized hostile
subjurisdiction.
The reasons for their flight,
the fear, the coercion, the
persecution are morally
identical to the reasons people
seek international asylum.
They were leaving places that
were unwilling and unable to
protect.
Them.
And yet, once again, legally,
they were not refugees under
international law.
No, they were American citizens
moving within the United States.
Their journey, as profound and
morally significant as it was,
was legally a matter of internal
relocation.
They were using the geography of
their own country to escape a
failed and hostile regional
government.
This distinction is so important
because it allows you to fully
acknowledge the suffering and
the terror of the Holy Family's
flight without twisting the
legal and historical facts.
They were internally displaced
persons.
The source material is really
clear on this.
These examples show that
displacement can be horrible and
on a massive scale, but it
doesn't automatically trigger
the specific laws that govern
international refugees.
Those laws require borders and
different countries and asylum
claims.
The Holy Family story fits
squarely in the IDP category.
And I think it's important for
you, the listener, to realize
that getting the legal category
right doesn't diminish the moral
weight of their story one bit.
Not at all.
In fact, it helps clarify where
the moral responsibility lies.
The failure of the Great
Migration was a failure of the
American federal system to
protect its own citizens in
certain states.
The Holy Families flight was a
failure of a local Roman
administrator, Herod, which
required them to rely on the
stability of the broader Roman
system.
So let's bring it all back to
the biblical text itself, to the
Gospel of Matthew.
If we take off these modern
political glasses, what is the
actual drama of the flight to
Egypt about?
The drama is not about borders,
it's not about immigration
papers.
The drama is about Herod's
paranoia and his monstrous
violence, and it's about divine
protection.
Dreams.
Warnings from an Angel.
Exactly.
It's about God intervening to
ensure the survival of this
child to fulfill ancient
prophecies.
The whole focus of the story is
theological.
It's about God's plan working
out within the political
realities of the day.
So when we try to force this
story into our modern
immigration debates, we're
really just setting a rhetorical
trap for ourselves.
We're slapping modern labels
onto an ancient story that was
never about those things.
And it works so well as a
rhetorical trap, because our
modern discourse loves simple
emotional analogies.
It's so much easier to say Jesus
was a refugee so open the
borders than it is to have a
complex, nuanced discussion
about policy.
So why is it so important to get
this right?
Why does this precision matter
today?
Why not just let the analogy
stand if it promotes compassion?
Because the modern debates are
about real, specific and complex
legal systems systems.
When you talk about asylum
processing or migrant caravans
or national sovereignty, you are
talking about things that have
immense real world costs and
responsibilities, and if you use
the wrong labels, you confuse
the debate.
So how does mislabeling the Holy
Family muddy the waters of
today's policy debates?
Well take refugee resettlement
under international law that
imposes very specific legal
duties on the country that
accepts the refugee.
There are costs, processes,
legal statuses.
Deportation is an administrative
action taken against non
citizens.
All of these things are designed
to manage the presence of
foreigners inside a sovereign
nation.
And since none of that exists in
their world, the story of the
Holy Family can't possibly give
us a direct policy answer for
our world.
It can't.
To say that their internal
relocation within the Roman
Empire should tell us exactly
how to handle, for example, an
asylum claim at the US southern
border.
A situation involving two
different sovereign countries
and international law is just a
rhetorical sleight of hand.
It's using a motion to bypass
the hard work of actual policy
making.
So let's just state it one more
time.
If someone absolutely insists on
making an analogy between Rome
and a modern state, what is the
only one that actually holds up?
The only valid analogy based on
the history is this.
Caesar enforcing Rome's external
borders against foreigners is
like a modern state enforcing
its borders against foreigners.
Rome absolutely did control who
got in from the outside.
They did.
From Perthia, from Germania,
from Arabia.
They, like any sovereign power,
decided who could cross their
external frontier and on what
terms.
The Holy Family was never in
that category.
They were insiders.
To call them refugees is,
ironically, to assign them the
legal status of an outsider
trying to sneak in, which is the
exact opposite of what the text
and the history tell us.
So demanding this kind of
historical precision isn't just
an academic game.
It's necessary if you want to
have an honest and productive
debate about these incredibly
difficult issues today.
It's the only way to figure out
who is responsible for what.
If you blur the line between
internal displacement and
international migration, you
lose the ability to say which
government or which entity owes
a duty to the people who are
suffering.
The two situations trigger
completely different sets of
legal and moral obligations.
And that distinction is the real
insight here, isn't it?
It's the thing that gets lost in
all the political noise.
It is, and that's why we do
these deep dives to remember
that history is complex and that
simple analogy is no matter how
good they feel, often hide more
than they reveal.
OK, so let's try to wrap this
all up.
The core argument from the
sources we've looked at is
really twofold.
First, the Holy Family were
lawful subjects of the Roman
Empire.
Yeah, they were insiders.
And second, their flight to
Egypt was an act of internal
relocation to escape a local
threat, not an international
flight to seek asylum in a
foreign country.
And rejecting that refugee
analogy, as the sources argue,
isn't about a lack of
compassion.
It's about a demand for
historical and legal clarity.
The Nativity story is about
God's protection playing out
inside a single political world.
That's a great way to put it.
We spent a lot of time on what
they weren't international
refugees, but let's end by
focusing on what they were
internally displaced persons.
And thinking about them that way
as IDP's, leads us to a really
provocative final thought for
you, the listener, to take away
from this, If we accept that the
Holy Family's flight is best
understood as internal
displacement, as a coerced move
within a single country, what
does that tell us about the
moral duties a country owes to
its own people who are displaced
today?
We see this all the time, people
forced to move by local
violence, by economic collapse,
by natural disasters, all within
their own national borders.
A crisis that happens deep
inside a country not at its
edge.
Exactly.
So what is the responsibility of
a sovereign state when it fails
to protect its own people in one
of its own subjurisdictions?
Is that obligation different
from the one we have to foreign
refugees under international
law?
And if a state consistently
fails to meet that internal
obligation, what's the solution?
It's a question that puts the
moral responsibility squarely
back on the sovereign state
itself.
A question that is incredibly
relevant today, reminding us
that some of the greatest human
tragedies happen far from any
international border.
Welcome.
Thank you for joining us on
this.
Deal Today we're diving into a
sharp piece of analysis that
really takes on the political
narrative around the nativity
story.
Right, it argues the Holy Family
weren't refugees at all, but
we're actually internal Roman
subjects just relocating.
Exactly.
So let's get right into how we
can make this already compelling
argument even stronger.
The core seizes here.
It really hinges on this legal
distinction between a refugee
and an internally displaced
person, an IDP.
And the material makes an
exceptionally precise case for
it, showing they never crossed a
real sovereign border.
Yeah, but what I like is that
the author seems to know this
precision.
It risks sounding a bit
academic, maybe even cold.
Well, that's the thing.
The defense against that,
against the charge of lacking
compassion, it only shows up way
at the end in Section X.
And by then it might be too
late.
They might just, you know, shut
down before they get to your
real point.
So here's the thought.
While the legal distinction
between refugee and internally
displaced person is central to
the essay's precision, the
material could more proactively
redefine the moral obligation
associated with IDP's to secure
the argument against charges of
lacking compassion.
Yes, that's a huge weakness
right now.
We don't want the reader
thinking the author believes the
suffering was somehow less
important just because the legal
term is.
Different.
Of course not.
The weakness is that by delaying
that moral defense, you let the
reader frame it as just
intellectual hair splitting, and
that's not fair to the argument.
Because the author knows that
things like the Dust Bowl or the
Great Migration, those were
profound moral crises.
Exactly.
So the suggestion is immediately
pivot the moral weight of the
IDP status right after you
establish the legal point.
Use those American crises not
just as legal parallels, but to
show the huge, demanding moral
obligations that internal
displacement creates inside a
single state.
OK, So you establish the legal
difference and then you
immediately assign this new,
maybe even heavier moral weight
to that IDP category.
That's a powerful move.
It is.
So let's talk concrete examples.
If we're going to put this idea
that rejecting the refugee
analogy isn't rejecting
compassion right up front saying
Section 2, what does that look
like?
Well, you use those incredible
modern analogies the author
already has.
The Great Migration.
Millions of people weren't
crossing international borders,
but they were absolutely forced
to move, fleeing state
sanctioned violence, deep
economic oppression.
That movement, even though it
was internal, created a massive
moral and political obligation
on the government.
That connection is key.
It immediately grounds this sort
of abstract Roman legal status
in a painful, very relatable
modern crisis.
Yes, it lets the reader accept
your legal point without feeling
like they have to sacrifice
their empathy.
So concretely.
Concretely, the author should
use the moral weight of the
Great Migration to show that
fleeing Herod's threat compels
an equally powerful but internal
obligation on Rome.
It immediately redirects the
reader's focus from border
crossings to internal protection
failures.
It shows that IDP status isn't a
lesser moral category.
Not at all.
It's a different one that
demands accountability from
within, and framing it that way
right up front protects the
entire argument.
That is a fundamental reframing.
It really tackles the arguments
vulnerability head on.
OK, so now let's talk about the
structure of the historical
evidence itself, the foundation
that Rome is the closest ancient
analogue to a continental scale
nation state.
That's in Section 2.
It's exceptionally strong, but
the full punch of that idea
feels a little delayed.
I agree the impact is fractured
right now.
So the crucial distinction
between internal movement and
external border enforcement,
which underpins the entire
argument, could be presented
earlier and more seamlessly
woven with the Roman analogue to
maximize the reader's immediate
understanding of the ancient
legal landscape.
Yeah.
The weakness is that the key
evidence, Caesar's strict
external border enforcement in
Section 3 and then the legal
status details in Section 5,
they're separated from that core
analogy in Section 2.
Which means the reader doesn't
immediately grasp the full
weight of the argument.
You know, the idea that the Holy
Family never behaved like modern
migrants crossing a guarded
sovereign line.
Precisely.
You need to create an immediate,
powerful contrast.
The structure should feel like a
quick historical reveal.
You say Rome is unified, then
you immediately show how
terrifyingly serious they were
about keeping people out.
Only to then show that this
mechanism never applied to the
Holy Family, right?
But right now we state the unity
and then we wait two whole
sections to talk about the
violence of that external
perimeter.
So the suggestion is clear,
consolidate the historical
evidence.
Bring it all together, both it's
unified internal law, taxation,
political identity, all that,
and it's violently enforced
external border.
Put it all into one powerful
early section.
And use that external
enforcement to create this
really dramatic contrast with
the Holy Family's internal
movement.
For concrete examples, just move
the core points from Section 3.
The details on Caesar enforcing
the Rhine, the Danube, the
Eastern frontiers, how he
repelled groups from Parthea or
Novatea.
Move that stuff directly into
Section 2.
That would create a much more
powerful statement.
Right after the intro, you
clarify that Rome governed from
Spain to Syria, and crucially,
that the enforcement mechanism
Caesar used on outsiders were
never applied to internal
subjects like Jesus, Mary and
Joseph.
Yes, it frames the entire rest
of the analysis.
And it means the author can then
deploy that killer analogy.
The one about moving from Judea
to Egypt being like.
Moving from California to
Nevada, Not crossing from Mexico
into the United States.
And when that analogy hits, it's
not just a clever comparison,
it's an historically verified
claim.
Because you've already laid the
groundwork.
It just streamlines the whole
narrative.
Maximum efficiency.
That's a very effective
structural adjustment.
It helps the pacing immensely.
But to truly, you know, lock the
argument down, we need to
address the historical
nitpickers.
Yes, the ones who will try to
complicate the idea of a lawful
subject.
Right.
The piece makes this bold
assertion that the family were
always lawful members of the
imperial world.
That claim is vital.
It is necessary, yeah, but I do
worry that a knowledgeable
reader might pause there.
The author clearly has deep
expertise, and they know that
historical status often comes
down to the difference between a
full Roman citizen and a mere
subject in a client Kingdom like
Judea.
OK, so maybe.
To solidify the claim that the
Holy Family were always lawful
subjects, the material needs to
briefly address potential
nuances in Roman political
status that might complicate or
challenge the monolithic view of
guaranteed internal freedom of
movement.
I see the risk by just ignoring
that citizen versus subject
distinction, you're kind of
leaving an opening.
You're allowing a counter
argument to imply there's a Gray
area in their freedom of
movement.
Even if it's just a
technicality, it could be used
to dilute the main point.
Exactly.
It doesn't actually change the
core argument that they weren't
refugees, but not addressing it
gives critics an unnecessary
point of entry.
The weakness is that a savvy
reader could imply the family
was in some kind of precarious
legal purgatory.
Which might start to sound a bit
like modern border issues.
Which is exactly what the piece
is arguing against.
So the suggestion is just to
acknowledge those distinctions,
citizen versus subject, and then
immediately clarify why, for the
purpose of the modern
immigration analogy, those
differences are immaterial.
Because their status as
protected members of the
Imperial world is what really
matters here.
That's it.
For a concrete example, we're
discussing the legal status in
Section V.
Just introduce a sentence or two
acknowledging the hierarchy of
rights.
Between a Roman citizen and a
local subject in Herod's Judea.
Yes, and then pivot fast Clarify
that regardless of whether they
had full citizen rights, their
legal status as insiders meant
they were never subjected to the
legal mechanisms like non entry
or expulsion that were reserved
solely for outsiders trying to
breach the external border.
That's critical.
You're basically showing that
you've considered the most
complex legal angle, and that
your central claim about border
integrity still holds up.
It's being pre emptive, closing
off that historical escape hatch
for critics.
You demonstrate mastery over the
material when you can address
the nuance while still
maintaining the force of your
main point.
And that's exactly what this
small adjustment does.
This is fantastic.
I mean, the author has such a
clever hook, and these
adjustments really push the
argument from just being correct
to being, well, unassailable.
It's an excellent piece of work
with a really sharp objective.
So the actionable opportunities
here are all about maximizing
resonance and robustness.
I think the key takeaways are
threefold.
First, place that moral argument
for internal displacement early.
Use the Great Migration analogy
to get ahead of any charges of
lacking compassion. 2nd
Consolidate the historical
framework of Rome's internal
unity and external enforcement.
Put it all in one early section
so that geographical analogy
lands with maximum force.
And finally, just briefly
account for those internal Roman
status distinctions, citizen
versus subject to preemptively
show how robust your central
legal claim really is.
These adjustments should
absolutely help your argument
achieve maximum impact and
clarity.
We invite you to submit your
revised material back to the
critique once you've implemented
these suggestions.
Every year we hear the Nativity
story, and almost immediately we
see its use in modern political
commentary.
Specifically, the Holy Family's
journey from Judea to Egypt is
often equated with the
experience of modern refugees or
even undocumented migrants.
It's a very.
Powerful analogy that gets used
a lot.
It is.
And so today we have to ask,
does the Holy Family's movement,
which took place entirely within
the Roman Empire, really justify
using these modern legal
categories?
Or, you know, are we imposing a
kind of historical and legal
incoherence onto the story?
My position is that the analogy
completely collapses because
they were lawful Roman subjects
moving inside a single unified
system.
And I'll be arguing that while
we have to acknowledge that
legal structure of Rome, the the
functional reality of their
journey, a desperate flight from
political violence, alliance
conceptually with the suffering
and moral urgency we associate
with the term refugee, or
perhaps more accurately, an
internally displaced person.
Well, my position really demands
historical and legal precision.
To claim the Holy Family were
refugees is to collapse these
essential categories separating
ancient internal movement from
modern international migration.
And this distinction is critical
because all of our modern law
and policy is built on the idea
of the nation state border, a
structure that was just wholly
absent from their world when
Jesus was born.
Rome functioned as this this
continental scale unified
political system.
You could call it a proto super
state, I suppose, governing
territory from Britain all the
way to the Levant.
So movement from Judea, which
was, you know, governed by a
Roman client, King Herod, into
Egypt, a direct imperial
province that was entirely
internal.
They didn't leave their country,
they didn't cross a national
border, and they certainly
didn't enter a foreign nation
state.
And that distinction matters
because modern refugee law, the
1951 Convention, is based on
crossing an international
frontier to escape persecution.
The Holy Family were never
stateless.
They were always subjects of
Rome.
The concept of an undocumented
person moving between Roman
territories just it didn't
exist.
To insist otherwise is to
introduce modern legal burdens
like asylum processing or
deportation, where they simply
can apply.
OK, I see why you're demanding
that level of historical
specificity.
I do.
But I'm coming at this from a
different angle, from the
perspective of human necessity.
We agree on the legal reality.
Egypt was Roman.
But that legal status alone
can't just nullify the
functional experience of their
flight.
The narrative as it's written is
fundamentally a story of
immediate coerced relocation
under the ultimate threat of
death.
I mean, this wasn't some clanned
economic migration.
It was a survival strategy
driven by Herod's political
purge, the massacre of the
innocents, this forced migration
shaped purely by terror.
It's morally analogous to the
crises we see today.
But what kind of crises?
Well.
If we want to find modern
parallels inside a unified
state, history gives us perfect
examples.
Think about the mass movements
during the Irish potato famine
or the Great Migration in the
United States, where millions of
black Americans fled systematic
violence in the South for the
North.
Legally, those were internal
movements, but they were
traumatic, they were morally
profound, and they required
finding sanctuary.
The story's power is in that
flight for survival, not in
Joseph's presumed paperwork.
That's an interesting point,
though I would frame it
differently.
I'd actually double down on the
integrity of Rome as the the
continental nation state analog.
Because you see, the moral
conclusions you're drawing
depend entirely on where we
place the vulnerability.
Let's just look at how Rome
actually treated its borders.
The sources are pretty clear
that Caesar strictly enforced
Rome's external frontiers, the
Rhine, the Danube, the eastern
lines against Parthia.
Now those borders function
precisely as modern
international borders do.
They were there to repel
unauthorized external migration.
The Holy Family never went near
those boundaries.
They were moving from one
administrative zone to another
inside the secure perimeter of
the Ox Romana.
Right.
I'm just not convinced by that
exclusive focus on the external
Roman walls.
You're making the analogy hinge
entirely on where the violence
came from.
Was it from outside the wall or
inside?
And while yes, legally they were
protected by Rome overall, the
most immediate brutal threat
came from a hostile government
official inside the system,
Herod.
A client king, yes, right.
So the disagreement here is
really about jurisdiction versus
function.
Yes.
Rome was the overarching legal
umbrella, but the threat was
localized and deadly for a
family in Bethlehem.
Herod's soldiers were agents of
execution.
Their flight was functionally
identical to fleeing a state
terror group, even if their
destination was technically
within the same empire.
That 400 mile journey was an
immense trauma.
It is the very definition of
displacement.
But that functional trauma,
while it's undeniable, is
exactly why we have to be
precise with our terms.
The distinction between an
internationally recognized
refugee and an internally
displaced person and IDP?
It exists for a reason, because
the legal remedies are
different.
An international refugee crosses
a border, meaning their original
state has failed them.
An IDP, like the Holy Family has
fled within their own state's
borders, meaning that state, in
this case Rome, retains the
primary legal obligation for
their protection.
To blur this distinction and
just call them refugees is to
dismiss the specific
responsibilities Rome held, and
it really muddies modern
discussions.
If we accept they were IDP's,
the analogy is powerful and it's
sound.
If we insist on calling them
international refugees, we are
imposing modern international
obligations on an ancient
empire.
OK, that refinement is helpful.
Classifying them as IDP's.
That does capture the legal
reality while still
acknowledging the coercion.
But the emotionally powerful
claim that they were refugees,
that often serves as a kind of
shorthand for their
vulnerability, for their
statelessness before the
immediate threat.
The narrative shows a family
seeking true sanctuary from a
hostile local authority.
So to just dismiss this moral
drama by saying they were lawful
subjects or ID.
PS It misses the immediate
crisis when Herod's assassins
are at the door.
Does Joseph's theoretical right
to appeal to some Roman consul
in Alexandria truly mitigate the
terror of that night, or the
necessity of just running?
I see why you focus on that
vulnerability, I do.
But let me offer a different
perspective, rooted in the
consequences of the language.
We use modern policy debates
about immigration and asylum.
They involve immense
infrastructure, huge
administrative costs, legally
binding obligations.
You have resettlement programs,
asylum courts, border agencies,
and these systems only function
because the distinction between
citizen and non citizen,
sovereign territory and foreign
territory is absolutely clear.
Sure, but.
And so to insist they were
undocumented or asylum seekers
is to confuse internal
displacement with external
crossing.
It imposes the modern
administrative machinery of
international law onto a world
where those frameworks just
didn't exist.
This lack of precision has
serious consequences.
Today.
It uses Scripture to demand
policy solutions like open
borders or a specific asylum
processes that are only
applicable to international
migrants, not internal ones.
We risk diluting modern asylum
law by overextending the
analogy.
I understand the concern about
diluting specific legal
categories, but that line of
reasoning suggests the only
vulnerability that matters is
the one validated by a modern
International Convention.
My argument is that the text
itself provides the moral
validation.
When we read the narrative, we
don't find a discussion of
travel documents, we find an
event driven by fear and the
search for security.
The vulnerability wasn't just
lacking a safe place to stay, it
was the lack of protection from
the state mechanism that Herod
was using.
But the source of the coercion
matters.
The distinction you're pressing
between an IDP fleeing internal
tyranny and an international
refugee fleeing the same is,
from a moral standpoint,
administrative.
The imperative placed upon the
host community remains the same.
Welcome those fleeing violence.
This narrative instructs on the
sacred nature of sanctuary, not
on the correct application of a
visa stamp.
I appreciate the focus on
sanctuary, but we have to return
to the source of that coercion
or we misinterpret the history.
If we must draw parallels, we
have to be precise Caesar's
enforcement of external borders.
That is the correct historical
analogy for modern border
control.
The Holy Family's flight was
motivated by Harrods internal
political violence against his
own subjects.
Confusing Harrods tyranny with a
modern immigration official
enforcing border law is the
fundamental error here.
Their problem was a tyrant, not
their immigration paperwork.
That is a compelling argument,
but have you considered the
theological function of their
journey, which I would argue
matters more to the listener
than the fine print of Roman
law?
The flight establishes this
profound connection between the
divine and the vulnerable.
Whether they are legally IDP's
or international refugees, the
story is still one of flight for
survival.
It highlights that even the
Messiah must rely on the
compassion of strangers.
We can't ask the text to answer
our specific administrative
questions, like how they'd fare
under current asylum rules.
But it provides essential moral
context about our obligation to
all who are fleeing violence,
regardless of which legal box
they happen to fall into.
So for me it comes down to this.
The claim that the Holy Family
were refugees is a historical
and legal confusion.
They were Roman subjects
relocating within the empire.
It's a story of internal
displacement under political
threat.
Using it as a blueprint for
modern international immigration
policy just confuses 2 very
different things.
And for me, the narrative is
about suffering and flight
coerced by violence, and that
reality connects the Holy
Family's experience directly to
the moral urgency of modern
crises.
So while legal precision would
classify them as internal movers
or IDP's, the moral weight of
their plight, the necessity of
sanctuary, remains central to
the story's power.
And I think both perspectives
really illuminate the material
by demanding we be clear about
the difference between legal
categories, historical context,
and and the moral implications.
Exactly, and recognizing that
complexity often requires us to
integrate both the legal fact
and the moral function to really
appreciate.
The truth and modern refugee
analogies.
You hear it all the time, right?
That Jesus, Mary, and Joseph
were refugees or undocumented.
But The thing is, the actual
history of the Roman Empire
tells a, well, a totally
different story.
First, you got a picture of the
Roman Empire as basically one
huge unified country.
Judea, where the family fled
from, and Egypt, where they
went, were both inside of it.
So they never actually left
their country or crossed a
national border.
It was more like moving from,
say, California to Nevada today.
Second, let's talk about their
legal status.
Since they were moving inside
Roman territory, they were
always lawful subjects.
They were never outsiders.
All these modern labels we use,
like refugee or asylum seeker,
they just they just didn't apply
to internal movement back then.
Sure, Rome was super strict
about its external borders, but
that wasn't the Holy Family
situation at all.
Finally, if they weren't
refugees, what's a better way to
describe them?
Well, their flight was an
internal relocation to escape
violence from Herod.
The best modern analogy isn't
international refugee law, but
more like Americans fleeing the
Dust Bowl or Black Americans
relocating during the Great
Migration.
You know, these were massive,
traumatic moves, but they
happened entirely within one
political system.
So the Nativity story is
fundamentally about divine
protection and survival under a
political threat, not about
contemporary immigration debates
or legal status in a foreign
country.